バッハ
配布
食べるコニーちゃん肇社長ですあのすごい意味不明な事を言いま
ボクスレってみたいんですよいやそので氷の上とかでもなくて結論した床とかではなく
て僕は普段のこの貢女生活における
声優の夕刊でもは滑ってみたばかりというかな小学校の時な掃除の時間廊下を雑巾を
消した後売ろうか濡れじゃないですかあの濡れて老化ってるなぁ
皆さん風俗友達からめちゃくちゃ滑るんですよあのは苅田港一番切りサーフっていく
だけで擦って擦っていくあの感覚あの感覚を取り戻したいと思ってますそこで僕ある
正気に戻ってきましたこちら滑る振るいかにも怪しですよね滑るブルー ruckus
リコーンスプレーというものなんですけどもう普通に探してたらあってこれなんだろう
よく見たら
ベールスプレーなんですよこれを使いものが占めるようになる
今回も簡単例会でこのするステレオ使って僕人の床を滑るようにしてわかるが本と旅は
カ月に分かれたんですけど
数っていう感じねあの雑巾武器でどうかを拭いた後もちょっと水がたくさんの花って
いる床をこと走ってピタッと止まった瞬間にするとすれば動摩擦係数がない感じは
たまんない必要版たり食後の掃除当番どこ月
絶対廊下ソースが好きだったので僕はもう廊下そうですかしたくなかって勉強はず
ベスプラやつだって滑る床を作りたいと思います石油系溶剤入ってる山や吸入飲用
が人体に害がありますので絶対人はないでください通気の良いところで使用して
ください
バナナも移動しなきゃバナナもお得になっちゃうかちょっと実際に軽く使ってみ
ましょう
前髪切りましたとりあえず道でぐらい滑りかっていうのを知りたいんですよね普通の机
にまず使っていますいきます
うわぁこれで果たしてどれくらい滑るようになりますねもういいのかな
総額3さてには4滑っすごい釣れるよそっち等他にもまだしっかりつけてないんですか
倒れますこっちだとん
んんすごいすごいすごいただこのステージを全部滑るようにしてみましょう
kazumi 滑る作りです
まず滑るよ釣れスプレーは本物みたいですね素晴らしい
じゃあちょっと実際に行かでやってみましょう2泊だけどスーッと滑れるようになるん
でちょっと実際に作っていきましょうはいちょっと水金図はダメなのでマスクしながら
とりあえず術でスプレーをいかに打っていきますだよ
5われすごいですね
でちょっと匂いがひどすぎるって乾くのを待ちましょう
そう
はいという気でようやく理科の準備が整えましたこれできっとれ育っこの頃のすべすべ
の廊下に戻れるって言って今回準備しますがこちら自らに滑りそうな発掘を準備しまし
た
俺んちの行くでもねスーッとする出ることと証明しようと思いますねあー
小学校の廊下の3月スタートのようにも再整備スペシャル第1戦ともできます
いますツイ2まあ
par
大好きの骨は大
俺の心臓を貫通していたはぁっ
って
daisuke
足がとーこー
とっ
car
ん